banane ist luca hat meine liebe freunde
ihr wisst dass heute dienstag ist und
was kommt am dienstag richtig das größte
format in ganz youtube deutschland nabu
stay for ich euch allerdings gleich
meine top tech talks der woche zeigen
möchte ich sagen dass ich sie eben auch
ein neues video hochgeladen habe und
zwar ist das eine rich sportscheck in
dem ich euch unter anderem eine neue
rolex zeige euch meinen neuen gucci
pullover präsentieren euch auch meine
neuen airports zeige also wenn ihr das
noch nicht gesehen habt folgt wer gern
auf täglich heißt der laser luca und
schaut euch da gerne an aber jetzt
fangen wir mit dem ersten video dieser
heutigen folge tik tok eustace
[Musik]
kann man was sagen das auch
nein das geht nicht mittlerweile gilt
für bülent wolltest immer
[Musik]
ich schwöre ich hatte noch nie einen
richtigen kampf wirklich das kann man
nicht beschreiben macht das bitte dich
zu hause nach das ist sehr unangenehm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
a
alles klar der super content bisher
hierzu beginne ich habe einen krampf und
ein typ die wahrheit geben genauso wie
bei einem deutschland umfahren als wort
benutzt wenn man etwas umfährt aber auch
als wort wenn man etwas umfährt
das ist einfach aber dass das man mit
finger in deutschland macht einfach
vorne und hinten keinen sinn aber ja wir
machen weiter mit einer nächsten sache
die auch vorne und hinten keinen sinn
macht
aha wahrheit
man kennt ihn freunde
ja das könnte auch einen tick tock von
mir sein ich habe mir bei amazone neue
decke bestellt und es ist so ein geiles
material hält so warm es nicht absolute
hammer
ja
lassen wir mal
so stehen in der tat wenn die schon
länger beiden videos nicht mehr weg habe
ist ein paar carlino wie gc david leicht
ich immer nur von hinten sehe geht es
mir eigentlich ganz gut aber wenn du
dich um dritte ich beim anblick deiner
visage immer in mein fell armin nack
alles klar danke für die netten worte
[Musik]
solche videos des baustoff 1000 dies
aber es ist auch wieder die wahrheit das
habe ich einen letzten folge schon
gesagt leute werden auf tik tok bekannt
mit dem bescheuerten sachen ich habe
letztes einfach reinigen sie die ist
gegen einen stopp schild gerannt
30 millionen aufrufe quality content so
könnt ihr mit fake erfolgs flexen sehen
aber ich das macht so ein spiel zu 10
und klebt ihr motor steckt den stil
angeknüpft so dann sind sie werden cool
oder schreibt die kommentare nicht
verlosen soll
ich weiß nicht ob sie das ernst weil das
ganze video wenn sie es ernst weil das
ist extrem süß aber wenn sie es nicht
ernst meinen und es ist einfach wirklich
extrem lustig so ich meine diese inhalte
sowie airports
[Musik]
es ist halt immer so gewesen wenn wir
bei freunden geplant also die haben
irgendwie schön dem bett gibt hätte man
selbst genau auf den bola auf einer
isomatte oder beschissen auf die nase
auf die nacht ein paradebeispiel von
personen die absolut überhaupt cage
haben gefühl haben sagt malek cops aber
ohne dass die lippen sich berühren
[Musik]
weiter mit dem nächsten ich heiße muss
seit erst mal kommen auf diesem schild
steht dass ich in diesem see ein hecht
befindet wenn wir aber genau hinsehen
merken wir die sehen gar kein echt das
liegt daran dass er sich unter dem eis
befindet
[Musik]
es ist die wahrheit
es ist einfach wahr jedes mal wenn man
so ein akkuschrauber die hand nimmt und
ansatz so erhält man ist einfach die
wahrheit und jeder der ist verleugnet
der ist eine blöde softbox gesichts
grätsche
in beiden fällen
definitiv tik tok der woche also lieber
user mit dem namen etv c noble du hast
für mich hier das tik tok der woche
gewonnen lassen alle malen schönen
brewster und kommentiert unter diesem
video und einen apfel weil dann apple a
day keeps the doctor away
[Musik]
april
auch gar nichts mit doktor weg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kann ich das auch gebrochen
[Musik]
was in der heutigen folge haben wir zwei
big dogs der woche also auch der user
mit dem namen cameron mcd 72 ist auch
gewonnen
[Musik]
dann schaue ich freue mich schon darauf
wenn ich selber bald ähnlichen rund
haben ich werde auch die ganze zeit und
schwarze mit dem welt frauen wie es ihm
egal
[Musik]
es gibt halt solche leute auf tik tok
nie so krank tricks machen und dann gibt
es mit der letztens mit einem dartpfeil
in seinen mülleimer werfen wollte und
das ganze ist schlussendlich habe seht
einfach selbst kobe
ich bin
rund 990 schießen würde
das ist eine typische samstagnacht bei
mir wo ich dann auch wenn ich dann bei
mcdonald's dann wenn wir dann da sind
dass wir dann dort sprachen lernen
gerade in amerika wo kommt ab und zu
wirklich krass ausrasten bei
irgendwelchen leuten die ihnen die
schwarze machen oder sich einen spaß
erlauben oder so muss man sich
anvertrauen andere karte zu zeigen also
respekt dir auf jeden fall gegenüber
hallo sie jemand deutsch ist nicht
deutsch
was willst du sonst
das ist 100 prozentig die wahrheit alter
das bin ich wie ich überlege zu werke zu
gehen das bin ich wie ich mich fertig
machen um zu merkels zu gehen ich im
auto alleine auf dem weg zum makers das
bin ich wie ich meinen ersten bei majors
bestellt das bin ich warte das bin ich
wie ich alleine bei merkels mein essen
ist ja das bin ich wie ich noch nicht
wie bestellt das bin ich und der mc
flury das bin ich alleine im auto auf
dem weg nach hause
das bin ich nach mcus essen das bin ich
wie ich gerade die zehn euro die
ausgegeben habe bereue
[Musik]
sag mal was mache ich eigentlich immer
im leben
egal ob eustace man absolut beschissen
ist das format die heutige folge tiefe
gefallen hat dann zeigt sie gern mit
einem daumen unter dem video hier
schaffen wir 50.000 likes das ist ein
mega krass und wird mir zeigen dass euch
diese serie gefällt falls sie noch kein
teil der user abonniert haben einen
kanal folgt mir gern auf tik tok der
laser luca ich habe dort auch heute ein
neues video hochgeladen und jetzt kommt
das outro
[Musik]